we should be okay now
okay
what's up connor okay back back back
thanks goofy appreciate that
what's up everybody okay this should be
better
i forgot to change some settings before
i uh
before i went live it's good now okay
thanks connor sims
thanks this one i thought let me uh
hey can you guys hear my fan is it
really loud
uh the discord server should
be in uh
should be in the about me section of my
u and my uh my youtube page
take a look at that
uh your channel
about discord server link
is in the about me section on my youtube
channel
it doesn't look like it's a clickable
link but if you just copy and paste the
link
let's take a look here copy
paste yeah if you copy and paste the
link it'll take you right to the discord
server
so there you go if you're looking for
discord in my about me section
is everything going well
everything sounds pretty good
uh i don't play braless brawl stars
skylight i don't uh i don't know what
that is actually
uh what's up ron lee what's up slater
what's up chirag
uh how's everything how's everything
with the uh
the stream guys are we doing all right
i am i am i am so tired but hey
okay
all right let's uh get disney plus
pulled up we need that right
give me marvel loki i wonder if it's out
yet right because it comes out early
nope still just one
so if i remember correctly episode two
is about 54 minutes
um it's a good episode
i i'm trying to decide what to say
without spoiling anything and i
i don't think i'm gonna i don't think
i'm gonna say anything at all so
i'm still trying to catch my breath from
a hockey game because we had to freaking
rush out of there super quickly
um how am i hearing my oh because i have
myself pulled up that would make sense
wouldn't it
all right it looks like stream isn't
that laggy anymore which is nice
um looks like hey
prajwal thanks so much for that super
chat
all right let me mute myself here just
want the chat pulled up here
sweet pop-out chat
oh that's perfect i play center
uh tonight we only had uh my voice is
low can you guys hear me now
um
hello hello hello can you guys hear me
the episode is outlook
not on mine yet
let's uh let's just make sure let's go
over to this pc over here
hello the voice is fine on my
on my phone it's fine on my computer
i think uh the people here say my voice
is a little low uh try
adjusting some of your settings because
on my phone it's uh it's fine and some
a lot of people in there are saying uh
it's pretty good
i'm good i'm an a-hole i am good uh
let's make sure
yup so that's where i'm gonna show it
pop up here
gonna be able to show a little bit of it
we'll put
this little guy right here in the corner
there we go
and then i'll be able to show a little
bit of it obviously not too much because
uh
copyrights illegal right i love
when people are like show the whole
thing and put the audio up it's like i'm
sorry guys i really wish i could but
i'd get in a lot of
and get a lot of trouble for that so
uh i do collect funkos um which i don't
know if you can see let me move this guy
right here i don't know if you can see
some that i have uh right here
uh i collect a bunch of them so we have
this is ed sheeran because i like him
thor
tony stark captain america zombie hulk
wonder woman 1984 and there's some down
here that i haven't really organized yet
um yeah so
move this guy back here um
there we go okay so something um okay it
says
it's out i have to use the restroom guys
i i gotta do it really quick before we
start
let's see if it's out uh it's out all
right
while the beginning is playing because
it's a recap i'm going to use the
restroom
i'm going to play this uh and let it do
the recap so
enjoy the recap i will be right back
okay back now i gotta get this off the
screen because
i'm gonna get in trouble oh i just saw
that a super chat came in
what a lightsaber duel for for
hundred dollars uh pre brands looking
for that super chat i feel like i would
lose so i'm gonna have to say no
i can't even tell you the last time my
lightsaber dueled
all right guys so right now it's just a
recap
just to recap
the barrier we're hunting is you all
right here we go
um some people are asking me if i liked
um this episode better than the first i
did but chris didn't
um he thought the first one was better
so
uh let's do with that
with whatever you will like um
i i personally
i like plot and story development so to
me
i like i like the second episode i like
how they went a little bit deeper and
there's some really really good parts
really good parts so we're starting
the green marble studios logo so
uh just so everybody's aware
we talk about spoilers in this so uh
so yeah so we're 1985 in wisconsin
renaissance
fair right because they kind of trick
you in the beginning
you're like oh they like in the
renaissance
era but nope and here come the tva
got myself a powerade here
um no alexander tristan it is not scary
cyber jack mephisto confirmed
so the tva has just showed up to a
renaissance fair
they have found a signal
for uh they have found a signal for uh
what uh i'm like drawn blink here it's
called uh temporal aura
that matches the variance
signature to each other next energies so
they are now
in a tent in a circus or in the
renaissance
fair
and they say it's a trap watch your back
a great battle is about to commence
the prize our princess
oh and the the variant loki
kind of does like a wanda hypnotizing
trick and takes control over one of the
tva agents and she's about to just yep
kills one the other one looks at her
again spoilers guys uh if you don't want
to be in here for all the spoilers
i need a hero that's what that's the
song we're hearing now
hi cat what are you doing
what are you doing having some fun and
then she is released from the spell
great freaking great freaking thing
variant loki is uh taking some reset
charges
now he's got a little device that can
open the time doors
android expert nope we're watching the
second episode right now
they are they're out on wednesdays now
slash uh tuesday
tuesday nights which is where we are
right now and there you go
the variant loki symbols
really i wish i could stream the whole
thing but i can unfortunately
jet ski
so it's very important what happens when
a nexus event
branches past the red line very bad
things
when the tva can no longer reset a nexus
event that's what happens when that
branch line
goes above the red line and that would
lead to the destruction of the timeline
and the corrupt collapse of reality as
we know it
and then he's gonna try to smack miss
minutes here but nope
listen to mr anderson he knows what's up
yes i have seen the second episode and
that's all i've seen i've only seen the
first two
so he's gonna give him the jacket that
i'm wearing right now
but it says variant on it
can i look like him hold on can i i'm
not as good looking as tom hiddleston
so it doesn't really work that well
a little squished the lesser loki
is what our loki says let me see the
back of that jacket
and variant
i don't think i can put these down like
he can can i
guess i kind of can sweet she just
called him a cosmic mistake
masked gamer gamer yeah i should have
done the the tie
i should have done that so now they're
seeing different variants of loki
it says look out for loki they're
different variants
no two were alike look at ogre
one says different powers
although most of them include
shape-shifting illusion projection
loki's just kind of explaining some of
his powers right now
says take a breath
so owen was basically explained to the
team
you know we haven't been able to find
this loki so whoever the low he is we
need an expert
and that's this loki
obvious says i'm not worried about you
betraying us because
you know we can catch you and how is
that going to help you get close to the
time keepers
which that's what's at stake the time
keepers
this is an important part too
nexus events destabilize the time branch
so they can't go
they can only go to the present time in
that timeline
it's released guys we are watching it
right now as you can see right here
so they're just checking out
all the dead people
so everyone's aware we're at 9 minutes
30 seconds
and here's the interesting part
loki's examining the dead bodies
i see a scheme and in that scheme i see
myself
so look he's just trying to explain
something about himself who they're
trying to catch
loki says he wants me i'm the key to his
plan and he knows that i'm stronger than
him
he's lying to him that's fun
so loki just cost them a bunch of time
let's do there we go
okay so they are resetting the timeline
and they're set that timeline and they
did not catch
loki the other loki and the other loki
took hunter c20
as a prisoner as a hostage and they said
is that he's never done that before
so this is a little bit out of the norm
for
for the other loki
statues of the time keepers
bunch of stuff we got there
i need to turn the subtitles on
rent slayers basically saying you just
botched this mission
insubordinate stubborn unpredictable
talking about loki
hi rocket
controversial
so basically
owen wilson's mobius is saying yeah the
mission kind of got botched but i'm
learning about loki which is helping me
learn about the other variant
loki is an evil lying scourge that's the
part he plays in the sacred timeline
poor loki
how are the old time keepers
and then big spoiler mobius says
i've never met him before
they want the variant cut
so she just told mobius
that this is the last chance she's going
to get
with our loki she's going to reset him
sorry sorry fam
so mobius says hey look he believes in
himself enough for me
to not have to believe in him and if he
screws up again he'll delete him himself
now loki's trying to talk his way out of
trouble
mobius just shut up please
[Music]
you're here to help me catch the
superior version of yourself i love that
so funny
y'all didn't see that you didn't see
that
hey thank you movie world i appreciate
that i love this you know
the other loki is better than you and
you can't take it i love it
oh
it dropped guys it's out right now look
i like this fire why are you sticking
your neck out for me i'll give you two
options and you can believe whichever
you want
a i see a scared little boy shivering in
the cold
and you kind of feel bad for him or b
just want to catch the guy and i'll tell
you whatever i need to tell you i
freaking love that
mobius is playing loki so
so hard i love it
alright so here's where it gets kind of
interesting and you gotta really follow
it
mobius says it's your last chance and
your last chance
is work you have to work
hey comic x i'm glad you like them
make sure you enter the giveaway
and now he's going see the timekeepers
again
now he's going
over each loki variance case files
so give me your unique loki perspective
on
on each of these
really lean into the work and pretend
that your life depends on it
basically this is loki's last chance and
he's making me go through all these
different paperworks
this is where it gets interesting you
kind of you kind of got to really follow
this part so i'm going to be kind of
quiet and kind of
do some explanations after
uh maybe i can post the giveaway here
hold on let me
find the link
since i've already seen this episode i
don't have to pay attention that much
i don't want to save to watch later i
want to share the dang link
there it is there's the giveaway in the
description of that video
um i think the reset charges are for
deleting the tva eventually
and i can't say that i have not seen
that far into it that's not a spoiler
that's just a guess by me
so look he's trying to pull a fast one
and ask for the files
that are relating to the creation of the
tba
classified files
on beginning of time end of time all
classified look you can't see them
reading
[Music]
and she gives some files on himself
she played him everybody knows you're a
variant bro
it's red on the back of your jacket oh
my uh
this is straight there right now
this part is crazy so he reads the file
and
uh hey thinks let you in mcnerney
change the name to wonder world foreign
i appreciate that uh destruction of
asgard this part's pretty crazy because
you know
he didn't experience ragnarok but it
here it's like telling them all about
the destruction of ragnarok uh how it
blew
up it gets really emotional about it and
i freaking
i actually really like seeing loki
emotional
side that we didn't get to see too much
of
then he starts to to to get a little
idea for those asking i'm at 21 minutes
and 15 seconds right now
uh my room looks like a japanese room
the adventure thank you
uh i actually love asian culture
specifically
korean south korean culture i speak
korean um so that's what i was kind of
going for so thank you
he's hiding in apocalypses
this is important
destruction of asgard to most of its
people
so loki has an idea now
chaotic alterations of a predetermined
outcome
complicated
it's a metaphor don't use my salad i
want that salad
i could do anything i wanted uh how long
is episode let's see i believe
it's 54 minutes yep
loki's just completely
destroying mobius's launch to explain
his metaphor
destroying his lunch
that's the apocalypse
so basically what loki just explained
well he's about to explain it
love it
i'm not taking you for a stroll on the
promenade lesson apocalypse
so basically what loki just said
is that the
oh this is the i'll stab you in the back
part i'd never snap you in the back
literally stab people in the back like
50 times
i never do it again it got old
so basically what loki just said is that
the variant is hiding in apocalypses
because no matter what you do
before an apocalypse right before it
you're not going to create a different
timeline
because no matter what the apocalypse is
going to happen
so right now where are they at pompeii
why oh here they are 79 a.d
why because the volcano is gonna explode
and everyone's gonna die so they can do
anything right now and it doesn't matter
it won't create a different timeline
branch
because it doesn't matter because the
whole everyone's about to die
never do it again
mobius don't do anything loki why it
doesn't matter they're all going to die
so anything we do could create a huge
branch
if you're wrong
mobius says we're not meant to be here
anything you can do can impact the
course of history
very small disturbances but look he has
a different
plan loki has a
a different different plan for uh his
disturbance
he's literally saying we are agents of
the time
variance authority and you're all gonna
die
you're all about to die
the volcano's about to erupt i know
because i'm from the future
so lucky just asked the question like we
are from the future right
it sounds like we are it sounds pretty
futurey
nothing matters
and then what is mobius c
zero variance energy
no branching in the timeline
you guys need to leave before you die
just saying
doomsdays
we're gonna find out so now they're
doing their work
working together
wake up wake up lookie let's take a walk
it's interesting that they need sleep
oh i like this part that magazine
the jet skis
why do you have it because they're
[Laughter]
awesome
hahahaha
have you ever been on a jet ski no but
he loves jet skis they're awesome
love that helps remind me what we're
fighting for
you really believe all this stuff don't
you
mobius i just accept what it is
the tva created mobius
odin god of the heavens
existence is chaos nothing makes any
sense so we try to make sense of it
my own glorious purpose the tba is my
life
it's real because i believe it's real i
like it i like it i like it
past present future there's no such
thing as free will
it's an over sub oversimplification
so the people of the tva are really the
only ones who are actually free
how does it end that's a work in
progress
while we protect what came before
they're untangling the epilogue from its
infinite branches
so essentially they're saying that
they're going to eventually
kill all the nexus events and there's
going to be an end of time
you called me a scared little boy i
called you a lot of things
you're wrong though
it's not freedom mr anderson i like this
part no one bad
is ever truly bad and no one good is
ever truly
good
so now he's remembering the scared
little boy from the
first from the first episode
you're very clever i know
uh i don't think they're going to ralph
bonneros in this show
now we have two variables
it is out we are going over right now
kablooey
it's candy do you not have candy on
asgard luke grapes nuts that's not candy
bro
all right so now so
from 2047 to 2051 that's the only time
that's the only time kablooey was sold
so they're gonna do a competition
i'm to use the bathroom again guys and
i'm going to give you guys about 20
seconds of this clip
because you deserve it and i hope i
don't get copyrighted here we go
oh
he is saying every instant is telling me
this is where we nail the
variant
he's convincing ren slayer to let
them go
she says there's not much i can do if it
doesn't work out
time keeper in the background
we're on all right now the mission time
uh the subscription disney plus is like
nine bucks or something like that
i'm at 34 minutes 35 seconds fam
he gives gives loki his knives and she
says
nap
so they're going to rocks rox cart
so we're going to roxcart because it's
being used as a shelter
class 10 apocalypse dang
i gotta redo my breakdown because i
think
i said something about a class 7
apocalypse whoops
if you see a loki prune it
the bad lucky preferably our loki says
and haven hills alabama presented by
roxcar
and there is a class 10 apocalypse
happen right now
a huge storm and a tsunami that is about
to kill
everybody it's the year 2050.
roxcart
we're going in looking for the other
loki variant
so not spoilers yet but some big
spoilers are coming guys so
loki used this as magic again
what the hell was that using my magic
to dry my clothes
all right
so now she says
loki is staying with me
look he says it's fine i'll go with her
you can trust
me
why is it the people you can't trust
always saying you can trust them
ain't that the freaking truth
so loki is going with her
but the other look is watching look at
that
hey malek tripper what's up man uh mass
gamer was my average week like
um kind of varies
so there's a countdown
but uh typically i try to get a video
done a day before now
big news can come out sometimes and that
would take
a priority so sometimes i'll just do the
videos but
i do a lot of research
on theories and stuff like that hit the
gym up
plays video games sometimes
all right for everybody watching if you
don't want spoilers
they are coming
what are you doing i'm shopping for
plants
could that be you
look he says yes
well guys for those saying you like
looking one better it's about to get
intense
that was loki it was the other loki
and now the other
loki is
inside of her and now the loki's are
meeting
there are spoilers coming up fam
you're the fool that the tva brought in
to hunt me down
and loki gets it oh you're me
if anyone's anyone you're me love it
check the bad bags for reset charges
guys are saying hey if you can get
people out here get people out of here
but of course
sir you gotta see this and here's where
it gets intense
so she's saying it's real it's real it's
real
we don't know what it is yet though so
our lucky is talking to the variant loki
he was inside of the body
of b50
and then the other loki takes control of
another body
uh
all right guys
you too scared to meet me face to face
show yourself
and here goes loki all right looky
you went undercover
so our lucky says i found you because i
have an offer for you
love it i'm going to overthrow the
timekeepers
cards on the table i could use a
qualified lieutenant
other lookie says i assume you mean me
so this lookie goes don't call me that
you can call me
randy
so all right the other look he says no
i'm not going to join you
not interested in ruling the time
variance authority
i know i love the way loki talks sheath
your smile i freaking
so hunter c20 is real it's real it's
real
i gave it away she says
i gave it away i gave away where the
timekeepers are
interesting
so b15 is out and they are asking what
status is
so they know something's up
and b15s uh
if you don't want to rule the tv what do
you want doesn't matter you're too late
i found your hiding place like that that
makes me superior loki huh
we're learning the plan now
lure us here so you can blow the place
up
oh but the other loki is gone ah
that has possessed another body
i miss randy though this look
loki his body is much bigger
there let's look all right like he's not
having a good time with us right now
he's again i would never treat me like
this
that's a big dude though i always can
use magic
he just used telekinesis interesting
all right loki says stop hiding
uh for those asking if we're going to
see the other low-key spoilers are
coming that's all i'll say
and if you had any artery on it loki if
you had any arnor
you'd fight me yourself but the other
lucky says i got stuff to do
b15 i lost him
just that looks like your favorite look
he betrayed you so there's there's stuff
going off
and it looks like you know it's the
reset charges that this loki is kind of
prepped
all right here's our loki getting pissed
what do you want from me what's it all
about
brace yourself loki and out of that body
all right guys spoilers coming here here
it comes
spoilers i'm gonna show it so
female loki love it lady loki
oh i can't wait to see more of her so
she's did her trap
she did her trap and all these things
are going off now
all the reset charges are going and
there's like a butt load of them too
going off
but they are falling at the portals so
where are they going where are they
going
and that's just what mobius is asking
where are they going and look at that
freaking just the timeline
is in freaking chaos
somebody just look at the sacred
timeline
red slayer's like what and then she gets
her stuff
and there everyone's being deployed now
i love it i love it so much
and then she goes
but here's loki and mobius is around the
corner
what happens
loki wait loki wait
bye
and that's it
oh i freaking love it
oh i love it so much
oh it's so good
it's so good
so freaking good guys oh
oof oh man
isn't it so cool isn't it so cool uh
this this episode was like a setup for
that ending which
kind of sucks but i actually i i really
enjoyed the episode
channels
all right let's start our discussion
let's get christopher up in horror
uh how do i do this oh no that's not
him
start a voice call sort of video call
there
we go let's see what i can do here give
me a second
code red code red yeah the reset charges
were kind of crazy
do i see i see christopher
can christopher hear me
i can hear you but i don't think my chat
can yet hold
you got it yeah i'm gonna see what i can
do with that
hold on let me try to the mine was up
and running
let me pull up your stream give me a
second all right here we go let's see if
i can
make all this work uh boom
that's the crystal what's that guys
we're just setting up all the streams
cmr
alrighty i love it i i know a lot of
people are already saying like
um you know it's like not people whining
about
oh it's whining just people are saying
that uh i mean you said it too
you said that you enjoyed uh the first
episode of loki
you know like more i need a backup i did
yeah i
more i think it's different because you
have to
uh you have to set it up and they set it
up in a really really good way
and this is kind of like a second setup
to
a second setup can somebody let me know
if warren's relatively loud or not
because last time he wasn't
nobody uh i know you are allowed good
sweet i'ma turn me down listen to
your own stream i just did it turned me
down it should be evil
all right sweet let's dig into it so
what
is lady loki i'm so glad it's finally
out because so many freaking people have
been asking it's like i
know i can't speculate at all because i
i know
so that's all i say i just like i've
seen it i can't say anything sorry
uh sean hayes thank you so much for that
super chat before it was one timeline
now it's
all split in what do you think it means
for the spider verse and so sony mc mcu
connect uh
i'm not sure about the connection
between sony and the mcu
uh but this is definitely setting up the
spider-verse like 100
that is for sure happening for sure
that is 100 happening right now so
there was a part i wanted to pull up
because it flashed really quick okay
there is something interesting on it i
just did
so after the charges that madame loki
dropped through these time holes
yes um
happened they pulled up a screen that
showed some locations where things were
going wrong
i did it and i just went to the screen
and listen to this
okay 121 1947 new york usa
1984 tokyo japan 1999 kingsport usa
1982 titan
oh interesting and year 51
holla holla so not just earth
earth they went other places as well
well you have to get
thanos right right and you have to well
titan is essentially where all the
eternals live
so in 1982 a charge was sent
well oh it's the other way gonna move
um
i think what we just saw
is the multiverse of madness i mean it's
got to be right how
there's no way they can control it once
it passes the nexus line and how do they
stop that
well i think it happened if that's
actually the case though it happened a
lot earlier than i thought
yeah so we have to take into
consideration
that lady loki has a different plan
than ruling the tva so right
i mean i'm just i'm just assuming that
her plan is to get rid of it
because annihilate the tv right because
so
this is what my thought process keeps
going back to excuse me
loki our loki right what does it say
like our main art main look
our loki wants he he hates
fate they talked about in this episode
everything is predetermined
past present future you know there's no
freedom
loki hates that right he hates it so the
other loki has to hate it too and let's
be honest lady loki seems a little bit
smarter than
art loki all right she's like she she
seems a lot smarter than our loki and
she has a plan right and she stole all
these things she's defeating all these
tva agents
um so i believe that her deal is
basically
i'm gonna get rid of the tva because uh
there's not gonna be destiny for anyone
i'm gonna make my own choices i'm not
gonna live
basically almost under the rule of the
timekeepers right because essentially
they
are the gods of the entire universe and
to go back to your point
no it doesn't just affect earth because
the sacred timeline affects the entire
universe
yeah every whole universe right
everything within it so
guardians of the galaxy wherever they
may be you know zandar
zandarians novacore uh captain marvel
wherever the heck
she goes to the cree the scroll
everything like it it affects the entire
the entire universe yeah i wonder
so sorry devin yeah go ahead devin
headdress uh
has a point that i actually mentioned in
my breakdown of this video because i got
to watch it before and do it before
who's the secret analyst um we're
assuming kane correct
doctor strange really has his work cut
out for him thank you for the super chat
yes i
that's actually what i say i assume the
secret analyst is king because in the
comics they
uh rent slayer and kang they're lovers
so and and also i'm going back to my
king
king is one of the timekeeper theories
because
they cut it out but briefly
when owen wilson is in the office when
he says i've never met them he goes
although
that one looks and then it gets cut off
and i was
i'm pretty sure he was gonna say looks
familiar okay
and that's because you know kang in the
comics has like a ton of different
variations variants of himself and we're
talking about
a time travel show that's talking about
variants
right so that just it it seems to fit
perfectly for me so i'm on the whole
king as a timekeeper theory right now
this is what i've been saying since the
first episode
uh i think that's where i'm at but
again i'm thinking um it's the chaos
that because loki even says you know
okay
you know where's the fun in that you
know no chaos where's the fun of that so
i'm i'm thinking that
lady loki and i hope we get like
an actual name to call her because she
said you know don't call me loki
lokia i don't know what to call her i'm
just going to call her lady loki for the
time being
lady i call him a lady
well she's called monkey in the comics
that's like an actual name for her
but um yeah i think she wants
freedom that's right here's the question
so in the trailer the first episode they
explain
so much about the multiverse and how it
was in madness
right and then the tva puts it in order
and creates the sacred timeline to cut
out all the madness
okay yeah is it possible because this
isn't the beginning of time this is the
beginning of the tva and beginning of
the secret timeline
and we know loki asked for a file on the
beginning of time
right it was classified they don't have
it right is there any chance that lady
loki comes from that time of pre-battle
world
and is trying to restore that so that
her and her regime can return to power
for sure for sure i think so she's been
hiding out this whole time in the sacred
timeline
trying to figure out how to bring things
back to battle world because she was
a very popular you know aristocrat at
the time her and kang who knows right
yeah and uh not kang but um her and doom
right
and she's trying to bring it back to
that destruction so that she can thrive
in the chaos which would be
more important than destroying the tva
but it would be about restoring her
order which is the chaos of
battle world from the multiverse it
definitely seems
like um she's been around longer
right she has some type of knowledge
right she she's smarter
um have we seen
r loki or any like variant that's very
close to ours like in the mcu that we've
seen so far ever like mind control
somebody like that
i can't recall i don't think we have no
of course the first avengers film but he
uses the scepter
but it has the mind yeah the scepter had
the mind stone
so yeah yeah yeah that's what i missed i
i mean this loki
randy seems
significantly wiser
yeah stronger and i think that's just
from time right i i'm with you on that i
think she's been
around a lot more right so i think it'd
be a really interesting play because you
know he asked
her specifically do you want to take
down the tva and control this timeline
and
she's not interested in that because
she's got something even bigger than
that
yeah and i'm just trying to think to
myself how do you get bigger than taking
down
the most formidable force in the
universe to quote loki
and you think it's just to have the
chaos and to rule over her i think
potentially
if she if she came from the multiverse
we'll call the battle world era
maybe that's what she's trying to get
back to maybe not maybe i you know i
think i
didn't give us a much they left us on a
huge cliffhanger i know and i kind of
like it like i hate it right now it
makes me i can't wait for the next i
hate it but
that's why because i love the feeling of
waiting for the next episode
i'm just trying to piece it together on
your own and seeing how wrong you are
that's fun too right uh what if all king
is all three time keepers yeah that's
what i said in previous video two he
could be all three
but one of the middle time keepers
definitely looked like jonathan majors
like a hundred percent like john
and that always goes back to the same
thought right because he's confirmed
so this is all so big picture real fast
this is all leading to kang
i mean king's already confirmed to come
right so it's like
how is how is it not and one thing i
think would be cool
is you do have a good version of kang
that's a time keeper
and then you have a bad version of kang
and he's like fighting himself
right like how cool would it be to have
like a kang vs kang movie
they wouldn't call it that but you know
there's different versions of king like
iron lad
you know is kang and uh
you know kills himself in the comics to
you know kind of prevent
everything um so to me
are you wearing the tva jackets i am
wearing the tv i just noticed
i got to represent i'm a tva employee
yeah i am a tva employee so
um big picture this is leading the
battle world
now 100 i can't wait i
want randy lady loki so we're going to
call her randy from here
i want her to be a part of them see like
from here on out forever
like i've seen her for three minutes and
i love
her excuse me
yeah i've seen her for three minutes i
love her and i really really want her
to be a part of it
so i think she'll be really heavy moving
on from here yeah here's a good point
that i've thought about before isaiah
richardson
i'm convinced that chronopolis is the
city in the quantum realm
and the tv is there that's why the
infinity stones and match don't work
just like mephisto kang is too big for
displacement yeah no
for sure for sure um and this that's the
theory i like
the most um
is that they are literally in the
quantum realm because it like exists
outside of space and time and everything
like i was about to say so is the
is the quantum realm in between
universes
or different timelines
yeah it's essentially just like you know
like the tba is because it uh right so
it's in the same realm
it's not necessarily in the same realm
and maybe it is it's the same realm
it's just outside of space and time
outside looking are there
like multiple dimensions where you can
look
yeah no my look here it just says tva in
the back
i am not a variant i uh i am a tva
employee he's official i am a tv and i
know you can't see warren he doesn't
have a camera hooked up maybe next week
we'll get that going
uh hold please i can try that
he's gonna try uh what can i do here
i don't even know what computer
i'm talking to you on that might be an
issue
dude any man says time works differently
in the quantum realm straight up yeah i
think you're right jake i think
oh ant-man um
it's 100 true though right so it exists
outside of the tva
so it would be a perfect spot for a
alternate kang
to like warren was saying set up
chronopolis his city and
maybe the fantastic four are trapped
there because
kang is reed richard's son hey let's
make it off
there's warren right there guys now you
can see him
just like that easy-peasy camera is not
very good but nah neither is mine but
that's all right there you're there in
real time
yeah okay so
i have to bring it to this because you
were talking big picture big picture
and i think for me it comes down to two
points okay
what's the difference between dropping
charges
in the tva
specifically and dropping the charges
on the sacred timeline right because i
feel like
those are two different purposes if
you're dropping charges of the tva it's
to destroy the tva
right but she could have done that
and that would have been loki loki won i
think
i think to your point i'd actually think
she did drop them on the sacred timeline
no i realized that loki our loki would
have destroyed the tva
correct so what different
angle is she getting at by not
destroying the tva
but destroying the sacred timeline
because she i think she's just kind of
like
by passing
that process of like she just went
straight to
like creating the multiverse madness
essentially
right i think she does she
she clearly doesn't care about the tva
she just needed their charges
she's above them she's smart about them
she i mean we saw
she she treated them like they were
nothing
now she's just wearing like rag yeah she
she needed the charges so that's why she
didn't like eliminate the tva
and perhaps that's why you know she
might have something else to deal with
maybe the tva is how to get to the
timekeepers you know
the girl did say uh was it b20 c20
uh you know it's real it's real it's
real i don't know what
it is that's a big question that we're
gonna have to talk about but she said i
told them
where to find the timekeepers and i
don't know how this
random tba employee knows what the
timekeepers are
right if owen wilson hasn't even met
them yet he hasn't met them but that
doesn't mean he doesn't know where they
are
right because if they're gods
you're not like sitting there trying to
defy gods you're gonna get killed
especially it is interesting though
because
it makes you ask the big question and
it's cool because owen wilson and tom
middleton or mobius and loki were
talking about
you know don't think about where you
come from or how it all works because
there's no point right
you're a frost giant who was raised on
asgardia got it right
and it's so but i'm going to go ahead
and ask one of those questions anyway
you would have to destroy the
timekeepers
that's the only way to get rid of the
gpa you can get rid of tv8
and can't they just reset it all because
they did yeah
well no no because remember so a very
important part of this episode was
if the branch line
gets past the red line right the nexus
event
that's a nexus event you can't reset it
so i agree with that so the tva
basically
has you know what now that i'm thinking
about it maybe
she is trying to get to the timekeepers
because maybe that's the only true way
to destroy one timeline because like you
said they can they can fix it right
right if they did it in the first place
the whole battle world scene
i don't imagine it would be impossible
for them to do it again okay so i think
i have it i have it
let's have it let's have it what's
happening mark mark this stream
because i think i might have realized
what's happening
this is the diversion she wants
everybody out of the tva so she can walk
in and find the timekeepers
oh yeah because they instantly all took
out right they all left
[Music]
your stick right her main goal
may be to eventually
you know cause the chaos to where
there's no one ruling it right that
might be the overall goal but to get to
that she does indeed have to take out
the time keepers so
this is a diversion she found out where
the timekeepers are supposedly from
uh i think it's c20 or b20 and
c20 okay so she supposedly find out
found out where
they were from c20 right then she did
all this chaos to make everybody get
deployed to all these branches
that were you know being created so they
have to go stop the branches now she
knows that's gonna happen she knows that
they're all gonna get deployed
these branches so they're all gone now
what is she gonna do stroll into the tva
and find the timekeepers at least she
thinks
i think that's your plan though right it
might it might not be as simple as yeah
i'm just gonna walk in and find
timekeepers right
but i think that's what she thinks is
gonna happen
mobius told us what they were doing
and they're unwinding the time they're
unwinding the quote was unwinding the
branches of the sacred timeline
until it all comes to an end and then we
meet together at the end
in peace doesn't that sound lovely so
they're actually busy doing stuff right
now
maintaining the order of the sacred
timeline and foreseeing
and writing everything that went down
right apparently they are
they're the ones in charge of the future
and like
creating they're actually writing it
right they're right in the future
so again loki ain't about that
no yeah loki loki don't
because it's the same like natural
man right referring like speaking
generally the natural order of a loki
right the the natural loki is
mischievous
right is kind of against order and wants
chaos but but keep in mind
loki's natural self wants to rule
so maybe randy female loki is trying to
rule over something hold on i got a few
super chats
garrett gutierrez thank you for the
super chat i feel like the series will
lead up to ant-man 3
the most i hope they dive into the
quantum realm now kane will become the
main villain yes i feel like
both of those are going to happen and i
hope they talk about the quantum realm i
hope they
reveal that that's where the tva is
parker
weston's cow i hope i pronounced that
right i'm so sorry if i didn't thank you
for super chat what an episode
love the impact that you and chris have
made in the marvel community thank you
for keeping us fans updated hey thank
you so much we uh
we're trying uh we love this stuff
marvel's our lives you know we live
together not sure if you guys know that
chris is just in the other room um
he's addressing some super chats right
now but
yeah chris is just in the office right
next to me we live together
um we work together every day and we
love
the community so thank you so much we
really appreciate that uh andrew s
thank you for that super chat my guess
is she wants to create havoc in the
multiverse and also destroy the
timekeepers
which is why she also rejected joining
our loki yeah
yeah i think for sure on that um
you just have to think what her ultimate
goal is maybe it's just
chaos maybe it's just nobody controls
my destiny but me right because that was
a big thing in the first part
or the first episode that was a huge
thing loki couldn't get his head around
that you know he couldn't get his head
around fate around destiny
you know and he mentions it again so
past present future like that's all
determined it's a big deal or it's a big
thing for loki
to wrap his head up head around are you
back chris
i am back did you hear the super chat
from
parker weston
says what an episode i love the impact
that you and chris have made on marvel
community thank you for keeping us fans
updated how you doing parker thank you
so much for supporting
and all of you guys for supporting it's
uh yes a dream for us to come through
here to talk about marvel with you guys
i know right um
uh hold on can you explain the snow
globe um
yes and no um i don't know what the snow
globe is or where it's from i've
actually looked when i saw it before
basically what it is is there are other
analysts like
uh mobius that go to these different
timelines and they take things that
won't affect that timeline because
they're gonna
be destroyed and basically they're
souvenirs so
i don't know where it's from there were
some things on there there's a katana
there
which i don't know that's from either i
looked pretty closely and i i couldn't
really
i couldn't really see anything except
that they bring back mementos
why not if it's not it's not good
because it's gonna get destroyed why not
maybe it's a timeline they particularly
enjoyed
i had three people ask so i'll answer
and then you can answer
do we get a doctor strange cameo in this
series i'm gonna say no i'm gonna say
don't expect
i would say the only and this is like
freaking me saying mephisto again the
only thing to expect is
kang because because it
it it's kang it's it's been made fairly
clear by marvel studios and i've spoken
with two spoken with a director
a head writer two directors and a head
writer at this point in time
they are focused on their show yeah
now obviously michael waldron who i
spoke to
did an interview with is writing doctor
strange the multiverse of madness and i
specifically asked him
if he did anything to like good night
he did anything that he's gonna have to
deal with later and he really danced
around the question which always means
yes
um but i guess he couldn't also
say no but um
i'm gonna say that the only person to
expect is maybe king i i think he's one
of the time keepers
i think he's that mystery analyst that
uh rinslayer was talking to
um that's what i think uh andrew s
thanks for that super chat
uh i believe i addressed you uh andrew
ross thank you for that super chat
uh wooden thank you for that super chat
if loki ruled the universe in lady lucky
real time that would actually be kind of
cool
um that would actually be kind of cool
and and going back to like what i just
said
uh the inherent nature of a
loki is what i'll say is to want to rule
right he said in the first first episode
real midgard
you know so uh thought charges were
supposed to delete branch
not cree 8. well right but so
[Music]
the alternate branches right but if she
dropped them
on the normal sacred timeline right at
different points in time
that would create multiple branches
because that's not supposed to happen
yeah just based off of what we saw she
dropped them in all sorts of years i
mean she had like
at least 30 at least 30. i mean
on this screen one two three four five
there's
six at least and that's not even all of
it because you can see it scrolls up
yeah there's there's no there's one one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten there's ten branches just on this
one
yeah um cell or soleil sodi
i saw that the series will explain that
evan peter's quicksilver appearance any
predictions
at this point how it will um
i don't know about this series
explaining that um
that wouldn't be something i would count
on i would say if anything
multiverse madness would explain it so
but maybe maybe you never know again i
think i think
the writers and directors for the series
are going to focus on their series
this one maybe we'll focus a little bit
more on the multiverse of madness
because it is dealing with the
multiverse and time and everything like
that and
decaying i think correctly so maybe a
little bit but i
i'm not i'm not expecting cameos i'm not
i'm just expecting i don't know
i'm expecting loki to kill the
timekeepers
or secretly discover that he's a
timekeeper
or something right like what what would
the big twist be like him being a time
keeper himself right
um i don't know
but i can tell you that i want randy
lady lookie to stay
in the mcu for a long time i think she
looks awesome i think
uh sophia the actor's doing like an
incredibly good job
at playing her we only seen her like two
minutes um
yeah so i mean
uh there's gonna be some big reveals
like where the
tva is um
and i think if we don't see the
timekeepers
i'm gonna be pretty disappointed for
those talking about richard e grant i
think he's
gonna be playing one of the time keepers
um
so yeah i don't know i
i particularly enjoyed that episode i
did
um i think the episode revealed a lot in
very subtle ways
whereas the first episode was like yo
look nexus events and multi-person
sacred timeline and then this one you
know having watched your backpack that
was probably a third time watching it
back now so
i had a little bit more time to analyze
and think about it but uh
it definitely there's just subtle
moments that if you
linger on what they say and try to
connect them it gives a ton away
it does um alexa you have
commented or you have super chatted a
bunch before so thank you very much
automatically one you guys are doing a
great job thank you we really appreciate
that
to enjoy the watch parties even at 4 10
a.m yeah it's 2
10 for us so philly on that one maybe
kang sent lady loki to cost chaos for
him to rule not sure
if you know what i meant no yeah um
because a part of me actually thinks
that
maybe the timekeepers aren't real maybe
rent slayer is actually bad
and it's kang controlling everything
right because if she's the lover of kang
maybe they're together and she's kind of
playing the part
and they made up you know this whole
thing um but yeah but then at the same
time
maybe kang isn't one of the time keepers
or maybe a good version of him is and
there's the bad version out there
trying to take himself down and he's
partnered with lady loki
um i i see some people talking about
enchantress i don't think it's
enchantress i i do think it is a female
version of loki because that is taken
straight from the comics uh there's also
big rumors and i won't go too much into
it but it's pretty good chance
that we're gonna get kid loki as well uh
and we saw a few variants tonight
they were weird looking um
weird looking
thanks for super chat do i think this
series will bring miles morales to the
mcu
maybe even spidey who has no way home so
here's my only
quarrel with that technically
miles morales exists in the mcu already
we met his uncle prowler
and spider-man homecoming child just
can't be you know his uncle
and he says i got a nephew and his
nephew is miles morales
so technically already exist i don't
know what their plan is with that
um but every time i think about the
multiverse introducing miles i think
well
the art exists um
if if that if that wasn't a factor then
yes
uh i do think eventually this brings
miles in
uh to hindsinha 5709 she bombed
vormir holla sakar
zandor ego titan yeah it is very
interesting
um yeah it's definitely uh
something to keep in mind there because
you know
oh
uh it's gonna have serious implications
on
everything you know i also like
you also wonder is this supposed to
happen it's like clearly not right
because the tv is like scrambling and
everything like that
and they're controlling what is supposed
to happen but it's kind of like at the
same time it's like maybe it is all
supposed to happen
but at the end of it all
i want randy
lady loki to stay in the mcu and i want
our version of loki to say
stay in the mcu i think people are going
to be really mad if at the end loki
is deleted it's done yeah right i had my
thought too if whether or not that's how
this ends like
does loki get removed i don't think so i
i
and and i don't think tom hiddleston is
ready to leave the mcu i think that's
the crazy thing though he's been in so
long
anything could happen at this point i
know i would
but but you could do so so one thing
that happens in the comics is he gets
you know turned into a kid maybe that's
how kid loki comes into it
and he becomes an agent of asgard so
kid local agent of tva you know
jones thank you so much for the super
chat do i think look it will show up in
no way home i do not
um i 100 understand why people are
asking that and
and uh you know are thinking that
totally get it but no i i don't think he
it would just be too much at that point
like it's already gonna be so much
like i mean you know what else they
could do
is delete well sorry this i'm my
thoughts a little behind you now the um
thought of whether or not loki gets
deleted they could delete tom hiddleston
and leave us with a lady loki as the
main
loki in the timeline whatever that looks
like at the end
and then you have lady thor and lady
loki and they can go off and
be mischievous together like maybe
they're just trying to
pass over the torch for loki would i
like that
i don't know i don't know if i would
like that either but it is definitely a
direction i could see them going
i don't see i don't see
randy getting along with jane foster
thor i don't see randy getting along
with anybody
exactly specifically jake thank you for
the super chat
is that jake hedge it is j catch and he
says could we
could we see kid loki working with lady
loki like she met other loki's before
i would be sad if he dies in this but it
could happen
i think so and i think that would be
cool to see
um cam k thanks for super chat you oh
super chat i appreciate it
so she remembered the time to create
branches instead of erase them
yes and i believe she did that to cause
chaos
to get the tva to dispatch their troops
so she can go into the tba and possibly
take on the timekeepers
uh noah havens thanks for that super
chat you think the timekeepers are real
uh yeah i mean the real the comics
and i do think that's the main purpose
of randy
i don't think the time to keepers are
fake per se i think they exist they're
tangible they're real
but if you get rid of the time keepers
the tva is gone because they created it
yeah so i've thought about that too like
are they gone
or they just have no direction and
they're kind of like
maybe they're free to go right the boss
of the company died and now it's to the
next person in charge
right but he created like he created
them and gave them that purpose so i
don't know i could see it just like snap
thanos kind of dusting away
tva is gone because somebody destroyed
all the time keepers but again if the
time keepers are king like you like you
think
then um they're not going to destroy the
timekeepers because we need k
you also wonder what powers the
timekeepers have
something immense clearly they're gods
of some sort
right so we'll see about that uh isaiah
richardson jr
thanks for the super chat enchantress
has already been the mcu ragnarok she
was combined with hela having her many
comfortable powers and even had scourge
yes they did combined
hella and enchantress they tigerati did
say that
so that that further backs me up to
where i uh
i'm gonna say i don't think it's
enchanters at all like i really really
really don't uh haiti thanks for that
super chat but what about season two
that's confirmed
um you know someone asked me this before
and i did hear that it was confirmed but
like the other day i looked for like an
official confirmation and i
i didn't find one i didn't think it was
confirmed i think
they just said they have ideas for
season two loki
yeah but they said the same thing about
falcon in the winter soldier
that it could have a second season but
there's no couple well they're doing a
movie essentially to you know there's a
new captain america coming
um why isn't there black widow movie
review premier access was available and
i'm sure someone seen it
i actually get to watch tomorrow so
there you go uh
the premiere is tomorrow uh i can't talk
about it for like a month though or
something
yeah it's coming out real early yeah uh
we're getting the premiere
preview for it uh we can't tell you
until it is before
we can't tell you anything until i look
at my email right now so don't ask
uh let's take a look here
[Music]
black widow black widow virtual press
conference
details no that's not it although that
is friday
uh there you go black widow virtual
press conference
and pre-screening uh
where does it talk about the embargo gee
so june 17th oh that's tomorrow
so that's this so we can say well
we can say we've seen it tomorrow i mean
technically it's tomorrow
we're good well no it's not it's the
16th or tomorrow
uh when is the other
doesn't say yet please let me know if
you like uh it did in
one email that i got hold on review
embargo is tuesday the 29th
and it comes out on the uh
yeah july yeah so actually a week before
we can do our review on it we can say
we've seen it
might have to delete this stream but
um yeah so
uh that answers your question uh cmk 908
thanks for super chat how lady look
exists if there's only
one timeline uh she's hiding this is one
of the big parts of that episode she's
hiding
in what are they called apocalypses
apocalypses
huge disasters tba can't
pick up her energy signal basically the
easiest way
so basically she has been hopping from
different points in time hiding in
apocalypses not being detected
and the other and the other times she is
detected she creates nexus events
let me talk about how funny freaking
loki is at the pompeii
oh i know right nothing matters you're
all going to die
we are from the future right we are from
the future right tva sounds futurey
goodnight guys thanks for joining that
was hilarious though i love
i love mobius and and loki tom middleton
and owen wilson there
there they're back and forth wilson's
crush
you have the elegant the elegant sarcasm
of the english
english loki and tom hiddleston and then
the brute american
it's so satire it's so perfect it's
hilarious
perfect oh well done and it does perfect
it breaks down
loki in a way you haven't seen it before
because there are so few people
who are actually capable of retorting
with such eloquence that he kind of
doesn't have a response i mean most of
the time we see him talking to thor who
right right i think as far as
intelligence goes
so it's like mobius who knows loki no
he's almost better than loki does oh
yeah totally
and then and then you get these little
one-ups back and forth
like when they were talking about the
different variants and mobius was trying
to explain loki's power and loki's like
well actually and you could scroll into
this huge scientific explanation of
using the abilities
it's super cool to see those one-ups and
to see that kind of vulnerable loki well
i
love how like mobius essentially is like
messing with him
he's like what do you need me i'll tell
you two answers you know i'll give you
two choices you can choose
i think you're a scared little boy and
we found out that loki took that to
heart
i think you're a scared little boy all
right and um i feel sorry for you
too i'll tell you whatever the heck i
want to tell you to catch this other
loki
right because he's he's consistently
said this look he's superior
um jay london thanks for super chat i
think lady loki is partially trying to
survive
after being apprehended and liberate the
timeline from the timekeepers who have
too much power yeah i think there's
definitely
there's going to be some truth to that
um but i but i do think
she has the upper hand on the tba for
sure i mean clearly right we
we we've seen that so maybe at first she
was trying to survive but over
time or over not time depending on
wherever they existed
um they've kind of like brought that
down
uh she's brought them down like clearly
all the hunters are getting destroyed
and they're supposed to be like first of
all they have like sticks that touch you
and disintegrate you
like just with a single tap um
i wish they sent me one of those
and it worked right um
so yeah i think overall the big question
that we are going to be tortured by this
week
is where did loki go well
we've seen in the preview in the
trailers lady loki and
are lucky talking just sitting down and
talking it's like a cave
right it's not like it's like a water it
almost looks like vormir
right it's not very clear kind of looks
like more yeah but yeah i know the scene
continues right
so
i think they're gonna have like a big
heart to heart and and maybe she's gonna
explain
she's definitely gonna explain what
she's been through
i think just because just by the way
that we've seen them talking
i think that's a i think that's a sign
that they actually are going to talk
about
just everything i think it's interesting
as well though because she's like i
don't need you i don't need you and she
leaves the door open
right because she's a trickster she's a
goddess
as well right so it's like you know um
and she's definitely waiting because the
portal closes right when he goes through
it
right so uh i don't think she's the main
villain i think there's something going
on with the time keepers
right i think it's k somebody in your
chat said the tva suss and that might
have been a joke but i think he's right
like
tva says as hell like there's something
going on back there that's yeah
not quite right uh ellie gore reviews i
see that i've been
i've actually been talking about that
quite a lot that uh rent slayer
ravana renslayer is the lover of kang in
the comics
uh i've talked about in my first
breakdown and my indian explained video
that i did
and uh there's something happening i
think there could be a couple of
different kings
uh i my only question is
would they reveal kang as a main villain
in in the loki series and then in
ant-man 3.
you know um
yeah jake says that the loki's together
is going to be an impact moment where
she's trying to pull him
to her side so hopefully he's right
there and we'll actually get a little
breakdown of where she's from her
backstory
in the third episode because i don't
want to go on for freaking
more episodes not knowing her backstory
like i'm really right yeah i want to
learn it sooner than later and i and i
want the next episode to start with her
being like yeah so i'm from before the
sacred timeline or
yeah you know whatever so i think we're
going to have a moment where
like mobius realizes that like the tba
isn't what he thought it was
his boss weren't what they thought it
was and then hopefully
we get him and loki and randy working
together because i think that would be
really cool
that's a funny comment man i would
totally fall in line with loki's
character wanting to
we'll say do himself in more ways than
one
uh and it would totally be in loki's
character to want that
um just gonna throw that out there as
well it's it's in line with his
character to want to you know
kind of do himself you know bye bingebox
so um but dang uh
there's a lot to talk about a lot to
dissect and it's fun
this like what i really like about this
is it it's fun
and i don't think well
i didn't think mephisto was too far out
you know far-fetched to talk about
appearing in one division it seemed
like it was going to happen and so maybe
it's going to happen with kang
everyone's going to say why did you hype
up king so much but i mean he's already
confirmed to be coming so i feel like
i'm safe just
safe insane i think maybe we'll get like
a thanos
introduction though like the first thing
like you don't really see him
somebody says his name or something like
that like well king is definitely a huge
villain
right yeah big boy he's a big boy
yeah we'll have to see there's a lot
that's coming up uh we're not gonna
figure it out tonight although i
you know quote me i i do think
um i think you put some pieces i think i
put the pieces together where i think
randy is intentionally causing chaos and
branches to branch out so she can do
something else
specifically get inside the tv and take
a shot of timekeepers
i don't i don't i don't think that's her
main goal right now to
to cause all the branches i think it's a
distraction so
um is there still time for them all to
go and fix it yeah
guys i'm gonna say stop the super chats
now because we're about to end cuz my
voice is like going away we still have
some videos to do
finishing up some videos but as always
this is awesome
we love these um it's nice that we're
getting our cameras working now
and uh uh greg over at the real rage x
might join us one night he's been
wanting to
he's just had some technical
difficulties some nights but uh
we're gonna get him in there my voice is
going out guys
so i'll just say yeah i'll just say
love you all thank you everyone who
showed up thanks for all the chats
thanks for all the super chats thank you
to everybody who's just sitting in the
background watching
uh these have been so much fun to do and
hopefully
my hockey games won't fall on tuesdays
for much longer because i'm just
absolutely
beat
but this is awesome you guys are awesome
the community is awesome
and i think it's about to get pretty
pretty good i
i like the first two episodes and it's
to me i
the first episode was fantastic and it
hits me in a different way than the
second one does because the reveal
of lady loki at the end to me is so cool
like that's
that takes it for me um it's just like
so cool so i
totally get why everyone thinks the
first episode is better
uh to me the lady local reveal made it
just super awesome for me so chris final
words
um see you next week guys hopefully
less sick and uh let's get some good
reveals from loki i can't wait
yeah so look out for my review
coming out at a time tomorrow
yeah really early
i don't think my notification is going
to go out for it
because i had to restart my stream
tonight which would be three
notifications in a day
so we'll see how that works um
so just look out for it uh not gonna be
a
notification so just look for the video
on your feed so
all right guys love you all see you next
week
woof woof mr anderson thank you so much
you're the best hit me up on twitter
i guess the last thing i need to say
should always